[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH MCCRARY: I
am so happy to be
here with this
audience this morning
and sharing this message--
claiming your value
as a technical leader.
This presentation is built out
mostly on my experiences, both
what I have done that's worked
and what has not worked,
and also observing others that
I interact with and collaborate
with and find out
what makes them
effective as technical leaders,
and just as importantly,
what makes them ineffective.
Sometimes you learn a lot more
from the "what didn't work"
and "that is not gonna
help us" side of the coin.
So my mission here today is to
share these learnings with you.
And I would just love to, during
lunch or during the other parts
of this, get
together, to meet you,
and hear about your experiences
and answer your questions
to you.
Because I learn so much just
meeting people and hearing
how you're doing and
what challenges you have.
So just a quick thing-- if
this helps you strike up
a conversation with
me, I care a lot
about growing leadership
opportunities for women
in technical product careers.
It's something that I try to do
within my organization as well.
And it'll be a common theme
through our notes here today.
Claiming your value starts
with understanding your power.
I find that a lot of women just
don't like talking about power.
It seems aggressive and
unattractive to think
about power.
OK, don't think
about it that way.
But if that's what
it does, it kind
of strikes that note with
you, think about it this way.
What is power?
It's your ability to influence.
And I think that everybody
here has some ability
to influence in some way.
So what we need to
figure out is how
we're going to take that ability
to influence, capture it, grow
it, hold it, and then
help spread it, right?
So when you're thinking
about claiming your value
as a technical leader,
you've got to think about,
where does my
influence come from?
Where does my power come from?
And there's actually some
organizational behavior
research that goes back about
40 years on this very topic.
I gave a similar discussion
with a group of women
in Boston Product.
Was anybody there?
Anybody here at the Boston
Women Product event?
OK, so this is all
fresh to all of you.
Great.
And what I said is, when
I conceived of this topic,
I was going back to
when I was in school.
There were five sources
of organizational power.
And doing the research
to update my notes,
it turns out there
are seven now.
So this is an active body
of academic research.
There are seven.
We're going to go through
those seven right now.
The first and probably the most
obvious source of your power
is called legitimate power.
It's your position.
Any position you take
in an organization,
whether that's in
industry, in government,
whether that's social
networks, and by that
I mean like where
you're getting together
with people to do things
as an organization,
you have a position.
You have a job title,
a job description.
This is what you're doing.
And there are
certain decisions you
get to make because you're
occupying that position.
That's what this source
of power is all about.
If you are the CEO or
president of a company,
you have a very different
sort of positional power.
But you just as much do if
you are the QA analyst joining
a new team have a
position of power
that you get to make
decisions from-- really pretty
clear and obvious.
It's also probably the one
that people overestimate.
They think, ah,
I've got this role.
Therefore, I get to
make these decisions.
I'm in control.
And it turns out you're not.
So we'll move on
to the next one.
Charisma-- so if positional
power is all about what you've
been vested with by a
job title, then charisma
is also called referent power,
is really what comes from you.
This is the expression of who
you are, what you believe,
and how what you believe
and how you communicate
it can influence others.
You probably all know someone
that has a lot of charisma.
Like, it's the person that
you go into a group of people,
and they just kind
of get others kind
of thinking the way they think.
They engage people.
That's kind of an
extroverted type of charisma.
But there's also
introverted charisma, too.
So if you're like me and
you are an introvert,
you can also have that kind
of charisma or referent power.
And you can grow it.
The third source is reward.
So this is you're
in a place where
you can deliver incentives.
On the flip side of
this, is coercive power,
meaning you can
deliver sanctions.
So I think in most
organizations you can probably
think of somebody
who, they really
derive what power
and influence they
have based on what they can give
out or what they can take away.
Sometimes I think about
in my organization
we have a sales organization
that they run very
much by production targets.
And if you hit those
production targets,
certain managers have the
ability to reward you for that.
Those are the kind incentives.
So those sales leaders
have a lot of power
that just comes from being
able to deliver incentives.
On the flip side,
we have some people
that derive power in
kind of a perverse way,
from being able to
deliver sanctions.
And I would tell you
that these are also not
great sources of power
because they're just
tied to your ability
to give or take.
And they're not really lasting.
They're not enduring.
So the next is expertise.
Expertise is actually
a source of power
you can influence for yourself.
You can grow your expertise
in a subject, right?
So expertise is when
you collect knowledge
and you collect experience,
applying that knowledge.
This is about your skills.
This is about how you
take that knowledge
and you apply it in the world,
and people recognize you
for having that special
junction of knowledge and skills
to apply it, right?
Similar, but distinct,
is informational power.
A lot of times
informational power,
I think, gets abused because
we've all worked with
or had some dealing with
the person who was like,
I get all my power from
having this information,
and I'm not going to
share it with you.
I'm going to keep it.
And that's how
informational power is
distinct from experience, right?
Experience, you're out there,
and you're applying it.
Information means,
really, it's just
about having access
to certain information
that maybe is not widely
dispersed or knowing it so.
I would say focus on
expertise and recognize
that informational power,
again, is very fragile.
So the seventh and
the newest-- and I
put the resources here
from some of the studies.
You can find there's
a lot of studies
online by these authors.
But the newest is connections.
I think this makes so
much sense in our world
today because we are getting
more and more connected.
And this is a great example.
This event and
the people sitting
at your table and the
people that you're
going to meet around
you, get connected
with them because having access
to others is a source of power.
It's a source of influence.
I have really come to
respect this much more
in the last few years.
And it's made a difference
in my life in a way
that I didn't
anticipate it would
maybe four or five years ago.
So think about how you
can grow and nurture
and hold on to your connections
and make some new ones here.
This is part about
building out your power
base and your influence.
So now that we understand
how to grow our influence,
there are these seven kind of
distinct ways and power bases,
and we can actually think
about them methodically.
We have a challenge.
And that challenge
is, how do I claim
that value as a technical
leader by asserting
expert power, referent
power, and connection power.
So this is really where
the how to do something,
the techniques, I would call
it, are going to come into play.
And I want to spend the balance
of our time here talking
about this.
So I've broken this down
into four challenges.
So here's challenge number one.
If you really, really
want to assert your value,
claim your value as
a technical leader,
take the risk of being wrong.
And this may sound
counterintuitive.
So let's look at effective and
ineffective ways to do this.
Effective-- pretty obvious.
Do your research and
defend your position,
have confidence in
what you're doing.
Now, the mistake I see
a lot of people make
is they do their
research, and they
wait to defend their
position until they
have 100% certainty about
what they're going to say.
You've missed the boat because
effective decision making
isn't about being
absolutely 100% right
with great certainty.
It's about reducing uncertainty.
Don't expect perfect
knowledge, right?
Your mission should be to work
to reduce uncertainty, not
eliminate it.
If you wait too long, then you
are missing the opportunity
to expand and assert your
expert power on something
that you've worked hard for.
So the ineffective side
of this is doing things
like apologizing for having
a difference of opinion.
That is a very ineffective way.
If you're going to take the risk
of being wrong, and then go,
I'm very sorry about
it, that's going to ruin
your referent power base.
People are going to say,
well, wait a minute.
Are you standing up for
that, or are you not?
And it will also diminish
your expert power.
Giving up on your
position too early
and then staying quiet
until you feel 100% certain,
these are very ineffective
ways to grow your power.
So get out there, take
the risk of being wrong.
Put yourself in the position
of having expertise and then
flexing it.
And I think this has
been the lesson that most
impacted my career growth.
When I stopped
sitting, saying I'm
listening to all of the
people around the table,
and I'm afraid to speak up
because what if I'm wrong?
When I started speaking
up, sometimes I was wrong.
But people didn't remember that.
People remembered that I could
stand up, make an argument,
defend my position.
That's what they remembered.
And that starts to grow
that power base for you.
Here's the next one, get
comfortable with conflict.
And I don't mean
physical altercations.
Else we may end up trending
on one of the boards
that Fernanda showed us.
But get comfortable
with conflict
is really about being able
to articulate and defend
your position in a
place that's comfortable
and also to call out to others
when you don't agree with them
and to do it in a respectful
and constructive way.
So effective techniques
for this-- many of you
probably read Stephen
Covey's "7 Habits."
It's a, like, old standby.
I read it every other year
or so just to remind myself.
And there's a habit
there called, "seek first
to understand."
So before you set out to
have conflict with someone,
understand what is it
that you're actually
conflicting over.
Understand the basis of that--
what are the facts, what
are the arguments.
And it should never
be about the person.
It should always be
about the facts, right?
I learned this
tip from a manager
in one of my very early jobs.
She always started off,
can you help me understand?
And it is such a comfortable
way to demonstrate
to the other party that
you're interested in where
they're coming from.
I don't agree with
you, but can you
help me understand why you keep
portraying the requirements
of this product in this way?
And can you help
me understand that?
And then that really
gets to the bottom
of how you can talk
about facts and you
can talk about what you're
actually conflicting over.
The flip side of
that also is practice
being direct and saying,
I don't agree with you.
Here's why.
Now, it's not appropriate to
say, I don't agree with you.
Here is why.
I don't trust your
taste in shoes.
It's really this is about
I don't agree with you.
Here's why-- my facts, my data.
Here's where I'm coming from.
Let's talk about it
in a constructive way.
And then just learn to
recognize and nurture
constructive conflict.
We probably have all been
around people who actually don't
practice constructive conflict.
They practice some
type of bullying.
And that's the
ineffective behavior here.
When you're diminishing
someone else's position
based on something other than
the merits of their claim,
you're being a bully.
If you're drawing on a
positional or referent power
of someone else-- well, I'm
telling you to do it this way
because I'm the-- fill it in.
And it's my position.
That's a terrible reason,
and it's a terrible practice
to try and influence others.
And then if you're
saying, well, you
know, the CEO said that
you need to do this,
that's name dropping.
You need to build that influence
from your own arguments,
not from referring to someone
else's referent power, right?
So get comfortable
with conflict.
Find effective ways to have
that constructive conflict.
And it is a way to move
forward and to move
your mission forward,
your goals forward.
This is be decisive
under pressure.
This is an area that I
get a lot of questions
about because I said that
the effective way to be
decisive under pressure--
there's actually
a way you can grow
that as a skill
and as a part of who you are.
And it's having a
decision-making system
to fall back on.
One of the things about
being under pressure
is you've got time urgency.
You've got stakes.
What are we doing?
We've got to make
a decision now.
There's no more time.
It's urgent.
We have people depending on us.
How are we going to respond?
And if you have a
default decision making
in the back of your
pocket, you can
push back on those pressures
and make better decisions.
And when you make better
decisions, and you're calm,
and you're able to
move forward, then
people will build their referent
power that you have collected,
you'll build that with them
and your expertise as well.
So here's an example.
I have a couple of default
decision-making trees
I fall back on in
times of high pressure.
Are the outcomes
of this decision
going to matter in 10
minutes, 10 months, 10 years?
And really, that's helping
me understand and respond
appropriately to the
scope of whatever
is creating that pressure,
driving the need to make
that decision immediately.
Another one, especially leading
products or leading product
releases, is around
what does this
mean to our employees, our
customers, our brand, right?
So if you frame it that
way, then your decision
is really defensible.
All of this is about making
not the perfect decision,
but making a decision under
pressure and being defensible.
I could be wrong, but I made
the decision, and here's why.
Here's how I defend my decision.
So that kind of
wraps back around to
don't be afraid to take
the risk of being wrong.
Ineffective ways of being
decisive under pressure
are reacting emotionally.
Hair on fire.
Oh, my god, oh, my god,
what am I going to do?
That actually diminishes
your expertise power.
It diminishes your
referent power.
And it makes other people
kind of like, ugh, I
think the next time
we have an emergency,
do I want that
person leading us?
Blame shifting is something
I see that's ineffective.
So I've seen very
senior executives get
into a very important
decision that
needs to be made under
pressure, and what they do,
they just start
blaming everybody else.
We wouldn't be here if
you hadn't done this.
But we are here.
Now we need to move forward.
So can we go back to
being constructive?
Or blame absorbing-- I
also see this happen a lot.
It's all my fault.
This is a disaster.
I caused it.
I'm just going to absorb
all the blame to me.
Why is that an
ineffective technique?
It's ineffective because
it's not always accurate.
Very rarely do I find a
single point of failure
in any kind of teamwork.
And secondly, when you absorb
that blame, think about it
this way, you're
depriving somebody else
of learning lessons
of how to get better
from whatever went wrong.
So when you're decisive
under pressure,
if the first response
is it's all my fault,
I've got to fix this all myself,
you're really not respecting
the fact that the team
can come together,
learn something, and do
better going forward.
So being decisive
under pressure will
be a way to build your
expertise and referent power.
And if you can
find effective ways
to just do that, just
get better at being
decisive under pressure,
it will help you grow.
The last one, the fourth
one, is beam confidence.
There are effective ways to
do this and ineffective ways.
I'm going to start with one of
the ineffective ways right now.
And that's expecting that
time in a job equals mastery.
It does not.
If you think that
just being in the role
is how you're going to
become the best at it,
then you need to kind of
reflect back on what else
you could be doing besides
just occupying that role.
The effective way
to beam confidence
is to really know
that you've got it.
You know your stuff.
And you do this by
honing your craft.
You think methodically
about how am I
going to be the best at this?
Another way that
you beam confidence
is how you interact with others.
So if you are the person
that gets the emails
and thinks that every email
that you've ever received
is somehow a personal
attack on your credibility
or your professionalism,
then you
may need to step back
because that actually
is sending the wrong message.
That's sending the message that
you're not confident enough
in who you are, the
decisions you make,
and the role that you play.
So how do you get better
of beaming confidence
in those interactions?
I think there's a lot
to be had from assuming
positive intent with others.
When you go into a situation
and assume positive intent
in your interactions
with others,
what you're really doing
isn't so much about saying,
I trust you.
What you're saying is, I trust
that whatever happens here,
I can rise above it.
I trust my skills
to overcome this.
So when you assume
positive intent,
it's actually a lot more
about beaming confidence
in who you are and
what you stand for.
Another thing about
beaming confidence
is sidestepping personal attacks
and bullying behaviors and not
engaging with them.
I see a lot of people
that are being bullied
or they are having personal
attacks that come after them.
And what they do is
they turn and they just
go right into the
trap of getting
into that line of thought.
They start getting negative.
They start getting destructive.
A really confident person
says, OK, that's interesting.
And then they just
keep moving on.
You don't give credence to
those other types of behaviors.
The last part I would say
about beaming confidence
is lifting others
up as you climb.
I know that I have
benefited greatly
from very competent leaders who
said, we want to help you grow,
and here's how we want to do it.
And that has made
all the difference,
and that's what I do
within my organization,
too, is I want to know how do I
bring other people up and help
them grow their professional
leadership skills.
That says about how you
feel about yourself, right?
You're not threatened
by other people.
The people that walk in the
door are not threats to you.
They're actually coming
in to help you and grow
and be a benefit to your
team and your mission.
On the ineffective side,
when you paint yourself
as a sole hero, a
lot of people think
that means they're
so confident, right?
I'm so confident.
I'm going to paint
myself as a sole hero.
It's actually a
very thin veneer,
and everybody sees through it.
And it actually belies the
fact that a person doesn't
have the confidence that they're
actually projecting, which
I would say goes back to really
true authentic confidence
comes from honing your
craft and assuming
positive intent, right?
So beam confidence.
That's the fourth
kind of challenge
to how you assert your
value as a technical leader.
I put a little
summary slide up here,
mostly because I know people
like to take pictures.
But also just as a way to wrap
up some of these messages.
You know, really asserting
your power as a technology
professional-- and I put
product professional here,
coming from my
background-- is own it.
If that's what you
want to do, then do it.
And it means honing your craft
so that it's authentic to you,
and that confidence
is authentic.
It's not that thin veneer
that sometimes we see.
Defend your position.
This is my comment here.
Defensible but wrong will
beat quiet and scared,
and it helps build
referent power, right?
So you want to constantly
grow your power sources.
You want to hold that power.
And then you want to
use that influence.
Sorry not sorry-- it is
unnecessary to apologize
for having a
difference of opinion.
This almost could be a
mantra that a lot of people I
work with on a daily basis say.
And I'm going to tell you
this is not specific to women.
This is also-- I have
team members I coach,
and I tell them, you
did an amazing job.
You knew all the facts.
You had the market down.
You defended your decision to
go this way with the product,
and then you apologized for it.
Why?
Why did you do that?
So have that.
Stand, own it, and
hold your position.
Remember, can you help me
understand as a great way
to listen and work that
constructive conflict.
Can you help me understand?
I'm respecting you
and your opinion,
even though I may
disagree with it.
And then build your
default decision tree.
Have that idea in your head
that when you are under pressure
and need to make
a decision, what
are the things that matter,
so that in the moment
you aren't overrun by the
panic of being under pressure.
And then finally,
assume positive intent.
You guys, you will
be right more often
than you're wrong about
the tone or the nature
or the motivations
of somebody else.
And if you just
assume that they're
coming into it with positive
intent and you react that way,
it really will reflect
more on you than on them.
And it builds relationships,
and your referent power.
And that helps you grow
your influence, right?
So my final comments on this
topic are be methodical.
Build your value methodically.
Just like with the
sources of power,
you can think about
them categorically,
and you can see that some of
them are better and stronger
and you want to work on those.
You can work on your craft.
That is completely within
your realm of control.
You can work on yourself.
You can decide, regardless
of how much this person comes
across being a jerk, I'm going
to assume positive intent,
and we're going to keep working.
You can make that decision.
That's working on yourself.
You can also work
on your network.
Being here, reaching out,
getting to know people,
that helps grow that
connection power.
And then finally,
whenever you can,
take the opportunity
to change the system.
And it doesn't have to be huge.
About a year ago, some women and
I were talking in the hallways
and we said, there's just not
enough leadership training
for growing our pipeline
of women leaders coming up
through this company.
And that is true for sales.
It's true for product.
It's true for working
in the data center.
It's true across the board.
What are we going
to do about that?
And so we decided we would
band together and create
an entrepreneurial
women's network.
And we would go and lobby
for money from our CFO
and our CEO to fund leadership
training opportunities
for all the women and men in
our organization that we felt
could benefit from it.
And the recognition was amazing.
We got a yes.
And now there are programs that
we've helped launch internally.
And it's a small system.
It's an internal system.
But we changed it.
So we had an idea,
and now that's just
part of what people
really look forward
to coming in and
working in our company.
They're like, oh, you guys have
this entrepreneurial women's
network that sponsors its
own leadership training.
That's really terrific.
So we didn't wait for the
system to actually change.
We went outside and
changed it ourselves.
And I think that if you
looked into your organization
or in your life, you would
find an opportunity to do that.
And again, it doesn't
have to be shaking
the world to its foundations.
But you can make that impact.
We've got about 200
now, women enrolled,
and that's great, right?
That's 200 more
than were last year.
So change the system.
So these are the messages
I would leave you with,
as you think about
asserting your value
as a technical leader.
These are behaviors.
And a lot of these
behaviors you control.
And there's so much in our lives
that we just don't control.
There are so many things
that we just can't influence.
But these things
we can influence.
And we can and we can do it
thoughtfully and methodically.
So that's the end of
my discussion here.
But I want to just
one last thing say,
please connect with me.
Let's use this
opportunity, during lunch
and during the
reception, to meet.
I would love to meet as
many of you as I can.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Great.
Thank you again.
And we'll do the same that we
did for our previous speaker.
We'll take questions.
We have about 10
minutes for questions.
We have some mic runners.
I see someone in the middle.
Maybe hidden over there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question.
You mentioned charisma.
And extroverted charisma
is very obvious.
But you also mentioned
introverted charisma.
What is that?
And how do you grow it?
SARAH MCCRARY: Ah, OK,
thank you for that question.
I consider myself an
introvert, and here's why.
I get a lot of energy
from being by myself.
And at the end of the
day-- and I spend 10 hours
during the workday connecting
with people, collaborating.
And it's exhausting for me.
At the end of the day,
I want to be by myself,
and that's where I recharge.
My brother, on the other
hand, is an extrovert.
He hates to be alone.
I know when he's not with
friends or with family
because he's calling me.
And I'm like, what?
Are you by yourself?
Yes.
Oh, OK.
So he gets his energy
from being with people.
He likes to make
those connections.
That's how I define
extrovert and introvert.
So I think introverted
charisma really
can come from the
quieter interactions.
And maybe "quieter" is not
the right word, but the more
one-on-one interactions, right?
So for a long time I was
like-- coming to an event
like this would just have
really scared me because I don't
know how to do small talk.
I'm like, how do you-- but
then I had to learn that.
Because part of my
role in my company
is to go out and go to
industry-type meetings and go
meet customers and
go where they're at
and go learn new
things and meet people.
So I had to learn
how to do that.
And what I finally realized--
there was a book recently
called "Quiet."
Yeah, so a lot people--
and it was like, what
introverts really like are.
We want to connect about things
that are interesting to us,
right?
We don't necessarily want
to talk in shallow terms.
We want to sit with
someone, and like,
I want to know
everything about you.
where you come from,
what you're interested in,
what's going on in your life.
And that's hard
to do when you've
got 50 people
around you, when you
want to make those
one-on-one connections.
But I think that's
where introverts go,
is that what I find
I do in my work--
so I'll translate this to
my work-- I call people.
And instead of
scheduling meetings
with two or three or
four sometimes 50 people,
I just will call people.
I've got time on my
calendar in the morning.
And I just hold that time.
And whoever I think I
need to call and talk to,
to make that one-on-one
connection, I do it.
So there was a guy I talked
to on Friday morning, Jerry.
He leads some of our
product engineering teams.
And I need to work
with him, because I
want to bring in some new
design talent for a product
that we're working on.
And we just haven't
been connecting.
And I just called Jerry.
I was like, Jerry, do
you have time to talk?
And he's like, yeah.
And within 25 minutes,
I learned he's
going to Disneyland with his
daughter over spring break,
and he's really looking
forward to having tea
with the princesses.
And I was like, seriously?
That's amazing.
Yeah, and then he plays guitar.
Then he gave me this
really-- I just started
learning to play the guitar.
And then about 20 minutes
in our conversation, I said,
Jerry, by the way,
I called, and I
want to talk about this
issue with the design team.
And he's like, you know what?
I've been thinking
about this, Sarah.
And within five minutes,
we solved our problem.
And out of that
conversation, I know
I grew my influence with Jerry.
And I know it's
because we started
developing that relationship.
It's also part of that charisma
that an introvert can build,
that I'm interested in you
personally kind of charisma.
Is that helpful?
OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, so my question
is about workplace manners.
I work on a technical
support team.
And so me and my team
members, we're very polite.
We use please and thank you
a lot and internally as well.
And I feel like everybody else
in the company, developers
and the IT team,
I feel like it's
perceived as a sign of weakness
that we say please and thank
you a lot, and that we're looked
at as weaker for saying thank
you, because we need the help.
So do you have any advice
on how to handle that?
SARAH MCCRARY: So let
me ask you a question.
Do you feel like you are
ineffective because you're
more polite, or do you feel
like you're more effective
because you're polite?
AUDIENCE: Less
effective probably.
SARAH MCCRARY: You feel like
it's making you less effective?
AUDIENCE: Well, in
regards to power
and being looked
at as an expert,
I feel like we're not
taking as seriously.
And we're looked
at as if we always
know less because
we're asking questions.
SARAH MCCRARY: Interesting.
So I guess what comes to my
head is because we're not
being arrogant jerks, we're
looked at being less expert?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH MCCRARY: Well,
maybe you start with that.
So we're not arrogant jerks,
but we are experts at-- I
relate to this because about
four years ago, the CFO pulled
me aside and said--
so I moved from Texas,
and I grew up in
Texas and New Mexico.
I still say yes, sir, and
no, ma'am to my parents.
That's how I was raised.
And when I moved to New Jersey
a few years ago, oh, my gosh--
[LAUGHTER]
So the CFO pulls me aside, and
she was our first female CFO,
and she said, listen,
she's like, I got it.
But these guys are going
to just tear you apart
if you keep saying,
yes, sir or no ma'am
because it just diminishes you.
You look like you're
subservient to them.
And I was like, oh my
gosh, OK, thank you
for pointing that out, Maria.
I'm going to figure out
how to work with this,
because it is authentic
to me, and it's true to me
to be polite.
And being polite is saying,
yes, sir, no, ma'am.
And I don't just
do that to people
who are ranked higher than me.
I apply that equally across
the board to everybody, right?
So I had to really
figure this problem out
because I think
it's similar, right?
We're being looked at
as being less effective
or somehow reducing
our power base.
So I did not come up
with a perfect answer.
I know you're waiting on
that, but what I did do was
I asked some of the
people around me.
So I worked very closely
with our executive committee
at the time.
And it just so happened
that two of them, one
was from Nashville,
one was from Alabama,
and one was from New Jersey.
And the guys from
Alabama and Nashville,
it's kind of like these
are regional cultures.
Also, they're both
men, and they're
both aged 25 years
older than me,
they both say yes,
sir and no, ma'am.
So why is it bad
for me to do that?
So anyway, we actually
had a talk about it.
We had kind of a team
discussion about it.
It helped me to put
it out on the table
and say, guys, I'm
hearing this feedback
that because my regional
culture is to say these things,
that you guys think
that that's bad.
And I got some empathy
from some of the teams that
were like, no, actually
we don't feel that way.
In your particular case,
I'm not sure of the players.
If it's possible for you
to call it out and say,
I feel like this is going on.
Can we break it down
and deal with it?
If that's comfortable
for you, that kind of
goes back to that being
comfortable with conflict,
because some people, maybe if
you just call out for them.
Otherwise, there may be people
here that have really good
responses that I don't.
So what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Nicole.
SARAH MCCRARY: Nicole?
If anyone has the great
answer for Nicole,
she's right over there.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I was
actually going to-- I
had a follow-up question to this
last one and also a response.
So I'm a developer at a startup.
And we're moving
really fast, a lot
of pressure, very young team.
And we had some
issues with that.
So one of the things that
we actually did was we
had a giant team retro
about how we use language.
And it was kind of shocking,
especially because the majority
of the team is men.
And there are certain
things that for some
of the women on the team they
felt like were maybe a little
pejorative, like
some of the lingo,
like even calling someone
a rock star, right?
There's something
singularly anti-team
about having a rock star and
praising that kind of behavior
because it's the
cowboy behavior.
And people just didn't know.
It was really interesting .
People didn't know
what they were saying,
and we were able to
create a kind of guide.
And some people
also felt that that
was like a little prescriptive,
and that was actually
what I wanted to ask you, If
you've ever had a dictionary
conversation about,
like, we use this word,
but what does this word mean?
And how do people feel about it?
And we're going to decide
not to use this word.
Like on our team, we don't
use that word anymore.
So I didn't know if
you felt that that
was like too prescriptive or?
SARAH MCCRARY: First of all,
so what you did is I think
is you called it out, right?
Which was kind of what
we were talking about.
So there's kind of a vote for
the column of just call it out.
Be brave and call it out.
Secondly, I have had that
conversation two-fold.
One was about the F-word.
So when I took over
a team, I came in,
and actually the CEO departed.
He was the founding CEO.
It was really rough.
And I came in, and I
found that there was
a lot of really rough language.
And I just said, hey,
guys, just so you know,
when you speak to me using that
word, the effectiveness of what
you're trying to
communicate to me drops.
So either you're OK with that
or just take it in consideration
if you want me to act the way--
if you want to influence me,
don't use that word.
Second one was the word "hero."
We had a hero culture.
And here's what I think.
When you have a hero
culture or a rock star
or whatever, I don't
think it's bad to say
to someone in my team,
oh, you're a rock star.
Your contribution was great.
But when you're talking
about the whole culture,
a hero culture is the opposite
of a teamwork culture.
And what I had to
get people to realize
is you guys are
promoting that someone
has to come in
and save our bacon
through their
individual efforts.
And what that's depriving
us of is a strong team,
because a strong team
never gets to that point.
So we've got to
figure out whenever
we see this hero behavior
having to come in,
we've got to figure out why.
That's a signal that
something's not working.
So it's not exactly the
dictionary conversation
I think that you had.
But I love that
you called it out.
Call it for what it is and
talk about effectiveness.
Is it making as effective as
a team to keep going like this
or not?
And everybody's team's
going to be different.
What your teams
tolerate-- so some teams
might say, you know what?
I'm a ninja, or I'm
the princess of data.
That's awesome if
that works for them
and that's effective for them.
But another team might have
those exact same constructs
and go, wait a minute.
That's not effective for us.
We do not want to be called data
princesses or whatever it is.
But somebody else might
say, yes, that's what I am,
and I rock it.
So it's all local.
Don't be afraid to call it out.
And I think that's the whole
message is have the courage
to call it out.
I've got so many hands.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MODERATOR: Last-- this
will be the last question.
SARAH MCCRARY: I'm
sticking around here,
so if you got your hand
up and you want to chat,
I would love to talk with you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for the talk.
I was wondering if
from your experience
there are any behaviors
or ineffective behaviors
that women engage in
more often than men?
Just so that we can
keep those in mind.
SARAH MCCRARY: Everything
that I talked about here today
I have seen in
both men and women,
maybe not always in
the same frequency.
So I hesitate to say
because you're a woman,
this is what you're
doing that's ineffective.
But I would say every
thing that I put up here
on the board today is
something that I've experienced
or I've observed,
or I may have done
that ineffective thing myself.
And you can take
that as a takeaway.
I've worked in
mostly environments
where female leadership
was in the minority.
So just sometimes the frequency
of what you get to observe
is different.
But I would say pick one of
these that resonated with you
and work on it.
I think that was
the last one, right?
MODERATOR: Yes, that was it.
AUDIENCE: Will you be putting
the slides up somewhere for us.
SARAH MCCRARY: Are
the slides available?
MODERATOR: I'm not
sure if the slides
are going to be available.
I can find that out
and let you guys know.
Yeah, I don't know when their--
what the next steps are.
So thank you so much.
SARAH MCCRARY: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]